[Music]  look  everywhere it happens it's it's all  connected by the sewers  and they all meet up at the house on  ebal street  let's work with the clown i'm not doing  this  what the hell put the map back  [Music]  what happened  uh  turn it off  when you're a i kid the universe  revolves around you  you think that you'll always be  protected and cared for  then one day you realize that's not true  because when you're alone as a kid  the monster see you is weaker  you don't even know they're getting  closer  [Music]  until it's too  take  late  my grandfather thinks this town is  cursed  that all the bad things that happen in  this town are because of one thing  an evil thing  bill if you'll come with me you'll float  too  much i  saw something a clown yeah i saw him too  what happens when another georgie goes  missing  or one of  are you us gonna pretend it isn't  happening like everyone else in this  town  if we stick together  we'll win  [Music]  [Music]  you